I don't think there's anything wrong
with chasing money I just think that
it's usually the quickest way not to get
it did you consider not going as rogue
as quitting and going all-in did you
consider the the practicality of 6:00
p.m. to 3:00 in the morning I'm actually
just curious there's no judgment or like
I'm only collecting data because I'm
fascinated by the practicality of it and
the fear that I have when people make I
want everybody to do what you did if
they can do it and my fear is a lot
can't and that there's a more practical
way than going from zero to a hundred
though some people have to go zero to
hundred because if they're half pregnant
they'll never do it it's just completely
interesting matrix right please there's
a lot of things going on I think first
of all the reason I push so much on
judgment is the biggest fear I have is
that he won't because you know one of
the things I bet when I look at them
it's interesting I'm like oh it's good
because I wonder how much he's driving
hyping him to get the team there like
you always need you need optimism and
hype to jump like the guys kissing a
girl or boy jumping and riding a bike
going in a pool have become fascinated
with these three events as children
because if you really look at it it's
hype like I remember hyping buddies and
sixth grade be like dude you can kiss
her like hyping like hiding or one like
looking at friends or the high pine
needed to like I was scared shitless to
swim or ride a bike or like like hype
like taking a jump you know at the same
token like you know like sometimes the
dude went in for the kiss and she
rejected him and he was crippled for a
decade you know a lot of people will
fail in business and so I'm unbelievably
you thirty years ago had no choice she
had a jump you do have a choice now
depending on the business you choose if
you open a health and wellness and JIT
if you open a gym you physically got to
be there you can't but if you're doing
in you know if you're doing content or
information or you could use content to
set up a grand opening that will win in
three years I'm just it's it's asked
literally just for data of how you got
there the other thing I'm a very big
believer in is getting people to not
feel like it's a scarlet letter if they
lose something nobody talks about at all
is your scenario you jump it fails you
reset and go back and get a job in the
craft that you had because of your
resume and you restart in four years
from now we have we so America is pretty
good at looking at losses in a positive
way compared to other parts of the world
where it's like a true Scarlet Letter
death forever but still even here you
know people don't know when to go back
from their jump because they don't want
the loss on the resume they made the big
to-do that they're gonna you're gonna do
it now it doesn't work and what they do
is they triple down into debt to look
good in front of people
oh you're preaching that I want you've
already done that I'm actually talking
about the next part which is having the
options to know that the game is super
long and that if the Bismil when you go
from ice-cold when you go from never
having a business to having a business
that's like literally asking me I'm
asking you to right now qualify for
Wimbledon and tennis
it's a lot harder than people think
you're grown you two are grown I'm not
trying to suppress by the way I'm
talking about the practicality of like
options I love that we live in a world
I'm trying to get people to like really
understand how to win this so much of my
success is completely predicated on not
worrying about all my losses which means
at times of you know my great losses or
the things I passed on maybe I should
have done Shark Tank maybe maybe maybe
not
I don't think I should have done it not
this late in I think I'll do my own
thing like you know like but I could but
luck I mean there's a lot of time you
know I didn't invest in uber when I
thought I made $400 I mean that's a loss
for like all the things that I've done
are things that I can't see what the
outcome let me tell you how the uber
thing might have not been a lost on
black and white paper if I gave Travis
the money like I always was doing at
that time I would have made three
hundred four hundred million dollars on
paper what if I had invested in uber and
that led me to giving a speech in India
based on it right and I got hit by a bus
and died like I don't like people are
just so like like didn't understand how
light like I'm so happy right now how
can I possibly you know look like you
don't know what life's gonna bring you
right life's complicated and way more
matrix down and that's why you know I'm
gonna start pushing this I said it for
the first time really heavily up there
like the ROI winning in life is
happiness not money people are just so
fun you know like when I'm most happy
and about is if you just love the
process like loving the process like
loving the debates in the kitchen if you
can get to like that's what that's what
that's what what it's great I believe
you I believe your vibes seem good like
you know like I think you know I think
that's huge to me it's time and talent
the reason I love hard work is its
controllable it's hard for me be like be
more talented
you know that seems like like when
people like you push hard to get a lot
of politically correct you know over
extreme European points of you get mad
at me for Gary you're it's unhealthy
you can't garyvee you can't go to the
grave with all your money I'm like dude
I'm not talking about money and I don't
feel like it's work when I love it
like maybe you don't like your job as
much like I don't think I can judge
anything I think the question becomes
what the next thing is
to me it's like to me what correct
correct but I also think that people
confuse it the vehicle then so the I
think people don't often get the right
vehicle for their destination you're
right it's a vehicle now my question is
what's your destination and if you told
me it was down the street I tell you to
[ __ ] walk not drive a Lamborghini
[Music]
so I don't think it's an evil or it's
wrong I think people are confused to why
they try to unmask it and for what like
how much do you want to make it's
arbitrary
what's a based on like we have to unwind
what's been pushed in our heads you know
20 50 70 to 496 what to me it's to me my
big one is can I do what I want to do
every day I was doing that running the
liquor store and I was making 57 I was
happy as [ __ ] I'm no more happy today
than I was at 22 I was pumped I was on a
mission to build a family business so
big so that everybody on earth would
always say I did the right thing by my
parents in the way they did to me I
don't think there's anything wrong with
chasing money I just think that it's
usually the quickest way not to get it I
really believe that I really do I think
when I watch people that are driven by
money I see a lot of unhappiness and
failure it's very common I think I think
the question is why what do you need and
do you have a sense of that because by
the way it evolves what he needed at 24
is different than what he needs now and
him and me and that you know so it
evolves to if we did the happy meter
here it's the people that are I promise
you it's the people that are doing what
they want to be doing like to me yeah I
couldn't explain to you enough and I
have almost empathy for the cynicism
around this statement it's unbelievable
how much I don't like money I like the
game I love my game I love the game of
building [ __ ] it's why building you know
a legacy is the best because it's like
triple compounding valuable right I love
the admiration I talk a lot about loving
rocky 6 because he goes back to not
having anything I talk about it a lot
it's the same reason I was selling
baseball cards on Saturday I was selling
baseball cards on Twitter on Saturday
450 bucks for a stack of cards I love
the game of growing you know like to me
the best part is the beginning I love
the thrill of the chase I wake up at 6
o'clock in the morning in the garage
saleing because there's nothing like
pulling up literally to this day I can't
replicate the high of going to a garage
sale walking into a yard of junk and
finding something for a dollar that I
know I can sell on eBay for 17 bucks is
a bigger happiness high than closing a 6
million dollar account retainer and it's
not even close that's what I want for
everybody because that's how they get
the 20 I believe that I really do so I
think the fear I have with chasing money
is its short-term behavior and it leads
to a lot of like negativity even for the
people that achieve it
that's why optimism or offense works you
know it does but I do think you need to
be thoughtful about the chasing the
money thing it will lead to a loss in
the macro I believe that I could be
wrong but that is my official point of
view and I've watched it way too much
you
[Music]